welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Attack on Titan full series recap before
the final part 100 years ago the Titans
appeared they naked creepy looking
man-eating Giants that hunted humans
almost to Extinction but some survivors
managed to build enormous walls and the
walls work extremely well they're way
taller than any Titan so for the last
100 years Humanity's had a relatively
peaceful happy existence but some people
are not happy like our main character
Aaron joerger who hates that humanity is
penned in here like cattle Aaron is a
real angry kid who likes to yell a lot
his best friend Armen is a smart kid who
likes to cry a lot and their other best
friend Mikasa is the strong silent type
who's there to keep Aaron in line one
day everything changes when a colossal
Titan appears this thing is taller than
the walls and it kicks open the gate
letting the Titans inside it is a
Slaughter and Aaron watches as his mom
is devoured by a Titan his hometown of
shagan is destroyed but the interior
gate is still intact until another
abnormal Titan appears this one an
armored Titan and oh it charges the gate
boom bursts It Wide Open now the Titans
are flooding into wal Maria and the
entire outer ring the bulk of Humanity's
Land Is Lost Ain jger vows Revenge he's
going to kill all the Titans every last
one so as soon as he's old enough Aaron
joins the military along with his best
friends Armen and Mikasa and he meets
some new best friends among the other
recruits there's Connie who's bald Sasha
who's hungry and JN who's kind of cocky
becomes aon's rival now the humans fight
Titans in a super cool way using odm
gear omnidirectional Mobility units that
shoot out grappling hooks and let them
fly around you got to get up high
because the Titan's only weakness is at
the nape of their neck pretty soon
Aaron's training is almost complete but
just then the Colossal Titan appears
again but this time Aaron joerger's
ready to fight back he gets up there
ready to take this thing out but just as
quickly as it appeared it vanishes what
is going on here but before it left it
destroyed the Gat so now Titans are
pouring in and it's up to our group of
recruits to fight them off it's time for
their first epic fight against the
Titans but oh Titans look kind of silly
but they are way faster and stronger
it's not a fight it's a massacre armen's
about to be eaten well there he goes but
oh Aaron grabs him and gets him to
safety how's he going to get out of this
one well he doesn't he swallowed maybe
he's not the main character with Aaron
out of the picture his friend Mikasa
takes the spotlight she is by far the
best in the class she's a Titan killing
natural until her odm gear runs out of
gas then things are looking Bleak but
wait what's this one Titan Attacks the
other and now it's his turn for a Titan
killing Rampage all right when he's
finally defeated something very strange
happens at the nape of his neck is Aaron
Jagger what is going on it might have
something to do with his father gisha
Jagger who 5 years ago gave him a
mysterious injection and the key to his
secret basement but that will remain a
mystery for the next 50 episodes Aaron
figures out he can transform by drawing
blood like biting himself so boom he's a
Titan again he grabs a big old Boulder
and uses it to plug the gate so this
time humanity has stood its ground so
now Aaron Jagger's given over to
Commander Awin of the Scout regiment
who's just a real smart good guy and
once they officially graduate all of
eron's friends join the scouts too the
strongest of the scouts is Captain Levi
who is an absolute Titan killing machine
and the smartest of the scouts is Hani
who's the scientist type trying to
figure out what Titans even are so
pretty soon it's time for their first
mission into Titan country but today a
new abnormal Titan shows up the female
Titan so now Aaron transforms too and
it's up Titan fight but she has the
ability to harden certain parts of her
body and oh beats Aaron handily now one
of their friends and fellow recruits is
Annie and I don't want to jump to
conclusions but she looks exactly like
the female Titan they lead her into a
trap but it doesn't work and she
transforms again it's Titan fight round
two and this time Aaron takes her down
we might finally get some answers but
something unexpected happens she hardens
into a crystal shell and that's where
she stays the rest of the series so in
season 2 Titans appear within the the
walls but where did they even come from
the walls were not breached but now our
gang is surrounded with them this time
are air and Christa amir's a real tough
gal and Christa's real nice and Amir has
a huge crush on Christa she's like hey
girl I love you sorry about this secret
she leaps off the tower and cuts herself
yes Emir can turn into a Titan too how
many people can turn into Titans what is
going on emir's Titan is a weird little
Gremlin one and when she comes to
hopefully we'll finally get some answers
we do solve one mystery of where those
Titans came from it seems like they
started at Connie's Hometown and one of
them still stuck there and there's just
no denying it that Titan is Connie's mom
yes it seems that all Titans are people
blah but how and why was that Village
transformed well it might have something
to do with the new abnormal they saw
they Nam him the Beast Titan but he
didn't stick around more on him later so
now after their latest brush with death
our one friend Rina has had enough he's
like yo Aaron me and barol are
undercover Titans on a secret mission to
capture you so just come with us now and
we'll stop all the fighting um wait what
yes our friend Rina is the Armored Titan
and bear told he is the Colossal so they
get him and are out of there soon they
have to stop for rest though and by the
way anyone with Titan powers can
regenerate any injury it'd be nice if we
finally got some answers on where these
two came from and what's going on but
they don't say nothing they brought air
with them too though she wasn't with
them and she's not saying much either we
do get a vague part of her story for
reasons unknown she was turned into a
Titan which was for many years a waking
nightmare but she stumbled upon right
and barlon Annie's undercover crew and
ate their fourth friend and apparently
if a normal Titan eats someone who has a
Titan transformation power they turn
back to human and now get that power
anyway the scouts catch up to him so
it's a big old Chase with a bunch of
normal Titans following but now rina's
chucking other Titans at him it turns
into a whole mess and Aaron jger comes
face to face with the Titan that ate his
mother he tries to transform but he
doesn't have the strength yet so he goes
to just punch this thing and oh it
actually works something unexpected has
happened for reason unknown Aaron can
now control other Titans what is going
on Aaron doesn't keep his Titan
controlling power it only worked that
once so once again we're left with more
questions than answers so season 3
begins with an unresolved mystery from
the start of season 2 there are Titans
inside the walls the high priest of the
wall religion seems to know something
about it but now he dies under
mysterious circumstances smells like a
government cover up indeed the powers
that be have decided the scouts are
getting too close close to the truth so
for a while our crews got to go into
hiding as fugitives and hunting them is
an incredibly skilled fighter it's Kenny
Kenny the Ripper he and his crew use odm
Gear with guns specifically trained to
fight other humans but there's still no
match for Captain Levi Kenny himself
though is a match for Levi in fact Levi
is his nephew that he raised in the
unders city until one day he got bored
and left turns out Kenny and Levi are
both acri who for a long time were the
Bodyguards of the king something in
their genes make them incredibly strong
Fighters which is why they're so much
better than everyone else and guess who
else's last name is akman it's Mikasa
yes it's not by chance she's that
skilled it's in her blood so now the
government's going to execute Commander
Arwin and disband the scouts but the
rest of the military is like yeah n you
guys are clearly corrupt they have a
little coup and the scouts names are
cleared but Aaron jger was captured
along with Christa why her Well turns
out her real name is aoria rice she's a
secret daughter of Lord rice who turns
out is the true royal family so Aaron's
chained up in a weird Crystal Cavern and
we actually finally get some answers the
royal family has the power of the
founding Titan or the coordinate which
lets them control other Titans that's
how the original King Fritz built the
walls 100 years ago they're made out of
Harden Titans so for Generations this
founding Titan has been passed down
through the Royal bloodline you inject
yourself with a thing turn into a Titan
eat your ancestor and boom you're the
new king but 5 years ago Aaron's father
gisha Jagger crashed the ceremony and
somehow he had the power to turn into a
Titan they had a Titan fight but Aaron's
dad won and ate the founding Titan
taking the power for himself then he
injected young Aaron who turned into a
Titan and ate his dad and now had the
power of both those Titans Historia
you've got to turn into a Titan eat your
friend Aaron and get the founding Titan
back in the Royal bloodline so that
sounds nice time to save the world but
Historia realizes the whole in story if
the royal family had this power for 100
years why did they never use it to stop
the Titans Well turns out along with the
founding Titan comes the memories of the
original King Fritz and whoever gets it
never explains why but is like oh yeah
now we got to stay within the walls so
it becomes clear her dad does not have
Humanity's best interest at heart he
just wants to hold on to power and his
story is like oh hell no time to break
the cycle and free Humanity from the god
King's rule but now A desperate Lord
rice licks the Titan potion which is not
how you're supposed to use it he turns
into a massive Titan Aaron and friends
are going to be crushed but Aaron found
the bottle gives Titans hardening power
and eats it so boom yeah now he makes a
hardened Titan thing and saves them but
Lord rice has turned into such a big
titan he can't even walk he crawls his
way to the nearest Village and the
scouts got to fight him they Ram some
Gunpowder down his throat and boom
exploded so Historia is crowned queen
but not bound to the will of her
ancestors and the day is saved now with
Aaron's new hardening power he can
theoretically patch up holes in the wall
so for the first time humanity has a
chance to patch up the holes in chagan
and take back the outer ring the scouts
ride out in force and at first the
mission goes well but but it was a trap
behind them a whole new crop of Titans
pop up led by the Beast Titan we briefly
get to meet him his name is Zeke and
he's Ry and bold's Commander and the
Beast Titans may be the most dangerous
he's a good baseball player turns rocks
into weapons of mass destruction so
commander Awin leads a suicide charge
and almost all the scouts are wiped out
but that about time for Captain Levi to
sneak around the back and oh takes the
Beast Titan out but seek is rescued by
another super weird Titan who runs
around on all fours they call the cart
Titan Our Gang blows up Rina but the
cart Titan's there to rescue him too and
now it's Armen who has a genius plan to
take out the Colossal Titan he goes him
into using a steam thing but he holds on
until I'll sacrificing himself but Armen
figured out using the steam burns away
the Colossal muscle mass and it bought
time for Aaron back in human form to
sneak up behind and oh get be to now
Lord rice had one more Titan creating
injection so if the Scouts can capture
one of the transforming Titans alive
they can take that power and Armen is
still alive just barely it's like hey
give them the Titan injection so it'll
heal him and he can eat bar tilt get the
Colossal but turns out Commander Awin is
also barely alive and Levi's got to
choose which one to say save but with
his last breath Commander awin's like n
let me die save the kid and so it's
Armen who's turned into a Titan eats bar
tot and now has the power of the
colossal and so it's an epic victory for
Humanity they finally reclaimed their
outer ring but we still have no idea
what's really going on but now that they
can get to Erin's old house in chagan
it's finally time to find out what's in
that Cellar the mysterious key opens a
secret drawer which has books in it a
book with a photograph of Aaron's father
and another family this is weird because
our people don't have photographed
technology turns out they're not the
last humans on Earth there's a whole
world out there yes our Wald city is
just on one little island they're next
to the Empire of Marley which is at like
early 1900s technology that's where
aon's father is from but he's an eldian
a race that is horribly discriminated
against forced to wear armbands and
living ghettos the official story goes
that Queen yir of the eldians made a
deal with the devil to get Titan powers
and the old eldian Empire used the power
of the nine Titans that people can turn
into to dominate the world and they were
awful and evil but eventually there was
a big war where Marley got eight of the
nine Titans and defeated eldia so the
eldian king Fritz fled with most of his
people to the island of parade Paradise
where he used the power of the founding
Titan to build the walls of racist
people's memories so they could live in
peace but many ens were left behind in
Marley where now they're treated
terribly because of their devil blood
but when gishy eger's little sister is
killed by marleyan police he's like oh
hell no we eldians deserve better he
grows up and joins the underground
eldian resistance now it's here gisha
meets his first wife who is a descendant
of the Royal bloodline that was left
behind so they have a dream if they can
take back the power of the founding
Titan they can use it to unleash the
million Titans that make up the walls
and stomp Marley to dust and the eldian
of Royal Blood who would wield it is
their son Zeke yes the Beast Titan is
Aaron's half brother and Marley recruits
eldians into their army because they're
the only ones that can use the power of
the Titans that's who Ryan and barol and
Annie were eldian warriors fighting for
Marley so Dr Gish Jager was
indoctrinating his young son Zeke you
have to pretend to be loyal to Marley so
you can become one of the eldi and Titan
Warriors but secretly you have to be
anti- Marley steal the founding Titan
and use it to lead the eldian revolution
this was too much pressure for young
Zeke and he ended up turning his parents
in whoops Criminal elans are taken to
Paradise where they're turned into
Titans so that's where the Titans are
coming from it's a punishment for them
and they serve as guards to keep the
island eldians inside their walls but
gisha Jager is saved by his guard who
turns out is a secret eldian in the
resistance too and somehow through
unknown means he has the power of one of
the nine Titans it's the one Aaron gets
the attack Titan he's like hey man I
have the same basic plan as you but I
can't do it myself anyone who gets one
of the nine Titans only lives for 13
years and my time's almost up you got to
take this one from me Infiltrate The
Walls steal the founding Titan and save
all ens and so he did that's the story
we know and passed it on to his son
Aaron but wait a sec the founding Titan
only works if you have Royal Blood which
Aaron doesn't but Aaron figures out why
it worked that one time when he touched
the specific Titan because that Titan
was his dad's first wife who had the
Royal Blood so now we finally know
mostly what is going on and so
relatively quickly our humans finally
eradicate all the Titans on their Island
they are finally free except they're
kind of not though because right across
the sea is an entire world of people
that think they're devils and want to
kill them kind of a bummer and so season
4 begins four years later over in Marley
we follow a new bunch of kids they're
the top eldian Warrior candidates to
inherit one of the titans the main ones
are confident girl gobby and her friend
Falco now Marley's at war with someone
and we get to see their Titans in action
by the way air was executed they gave
her Titan to a new guy its proper name
is the jaw Titan anyway as we get to
know these people we see they really
aren't bad and Rina also who we've
thought of as an enemy but is a decent
guy he and his crew thought they were
making their country proud as they were
shipped off as kids on an undercover
genocide Mission anyway now with the
recent War one it's time to focus on
parody again they have a big event to
announce they're finally going to go
wipe out those eldian Devils but one of
them is closer than they think it's
long-haired adult Aaron Jagger oh Titan
attack yes a bunch of Scouts are here
ready to fight in the modern world it's
a massive fight all the Marley Titans
join in but our crew with their odm gear
are deadly but now mik says like Aaron
what have you done you just killed
thousands of civilians and our new kid
gobby having seen a bunch of her friends
die swears Vengeance just like Aaron did
all those years ago our crew escapes on
their new Airship but gob's not letting
them get away she and Falco get aboard
and shoots the first person she sees
which is no not Sasha she was so nice
just loved to eat going back a few years
to see how we got here our people
captured one of the marleyan Scout ships
but the tall girl in command here is
like Hey we're part of the eldian
resistance against Marley we want to be
friends so they helped our wall people
get modern technology and meet some
allies out in the world this country was
allies with the old eldian Empire and
turns out their Queen went behind the
walls too and it's mikasa's ancestor so
she's a princess and speaking of
princesses in case it matters Historia
is pregnant at the time they had high
hopes that they would be able to come
out to the world like hey we are not
Devils we don't want to conquer you
please let's all live in peace but aru
soon discovered that the world hated
them more than they even thought and
that's when Aaron left them and went on
his own secret plan to launch the first
strike attack on Marley most of the
military including aon's friends all
think this attack was a bad idea but
there's a lot of them who think that
Aaron had the right of it and are ready
to conquer the world as the new eldian
Empire and soon Aaron breaks himself out
of prison to lead this group called The
joer ists and Aaron joerger has grown up
from an annoying angry yelling kid to a
badass Stone Cold Rebel leader now back
in the city Marley and airships are here
for their Counterattack and leading the
assault is our old friend Rina who is
the Armored Titan and he and Aaron have
an epic rematch the Beast Titan joins
the battle but remember he's fighting
against Marley now Zeke's real goal is
to touch Aaron uniting the founding
Titan with a member of Royal Blood they
can actually use its power so Marley's
main goal is not to let that happen they
blast Zeke to take him out but he's not
dead so now he has to play his trump
card we learned that it's Zeke spinal
fluid that if ingest it he can turn him
into Titans somewhat under his control
and turns out the wine his friends
brought from Marley were spiked with his
juices he screams transforming all the
parody eldians that drank the wine
spiked with the spinal fluid into Titans
Falco accidentally drank some of the
wine so he's a Titan too now and rushes
over to attack Rina but way to's this
come to sacrifice himself to save Rina
it's their other friend who has the jaw
Titan and oh now Falco eats him got the
power of the jaw so now Rina continues
to beat up Aaron but Aaron jger pulls a
trick he hardens to tr ra Rina there
then leaves his body and makes a run for
it because Zeke is still alive and he's
going to touch him but now who's this
it's little gobby with a sniper rifle
boom Oh She Blows Aaron's head clean off
but if there's one thing we know about
Zeke he loves playing baseball and he
makes the diving catch and Aaron's brain
was just alive enough they've
successfully done it they are in the
coordinate of all eldians with their
founder imir so Zeke who witnessed all
the eldian suffering doesn't agree with
his dad that they should dries up he
thinks it would be best if they just
disappeared apparently his real plan is
to take the founding Titan and use it to
sterilize all eldians so they and Titans
will disappear from the earth now at
first Zeke is chained up it's like Aaron
actually you have the power here and
Aaron's like well psych bro I'm not
doing your plan I'm doing my own plan
but now Zeke is like yo double psych I
was just pretending to not have power
here so you would reveal your true
intentions long story short they go on a
journey through the memories of their
father gisher and turns out he didn't go
through with his plan to kill the royal
family and steal the founding Titan cuz
you know it wouldn't involveed
massacring these kids but then Aaron
Jagger starts talking to his father who
can hear him it's like what's up Dad I'm
the spirit of your son from the future
here to tell you you got to go through
with it trust me so somehow it was Aaron
joerger himself who started this whole
adventure to get to this present moment
cuz now it's like triple psych bro I
actually do somehow have the power here
so now Zeke tells air to sterilize all
the eldians and Aaron goes over to stop
her and this whole series it's been a
mystery who actually was air and how did
she end up with the Titan power turns
out deir wasn't eldian herself she was a
slave of the ens who were confirmed
terrible people somehow she fell into
this water with a weird jellyfish
vertebrae thing that oh turned her into
the first Titan but air spent her whole
life as a slave she only knew obedience
to the eldian king Fritz and so used her
Titan powers to join his army and help
conquer the world in fact she had King
Fritz's children and one day sacrificed
herself to save him to keep the Titan
power they had her children eat her and
that's how we got the nine Titans so now
Aaron grabs her like yo it's time to
stop being a slave it's time for you to
fight back and she's like you know what
bro you're right so somehow she passes
the founding Titan power to Aaron and
now we realize Aaron's true plan is not
to threaten the rumbling to keep Marley
away but to unleash it right now yes the
walls are coming down a million colossal
Titans headed to the mainland the
rumbling is here Aaron psychically talks
to all the eldians like hey what's up
guys it's like look the outside world
hates us and that's just not going to
change the only way my home the island
of paradise can ever really be safe is
if we wipe out every other person on the
planet and yeah I mean that's obviously
awful but it's rough cuz he's kind of
right so the rumbling is happening and
doesn't look like anyone can stop it the
jurists LED a coup to take over parodies
they're led by this red-haired guy flock
but unfortunately he's got kind of a
dictator Vibe and executes anyone not on
his side this leaves any marleyan
survivors like Peak the cart Titan as
enemies of the state and also enemies of
the state our commander Hani and an
injured but alive Captain Levi it's like
yo we're not with the jurists let's be
allies and all of Aaron's friends
friends are in on the plan and they
recruit another old friend it's Annie
yeah when Aaron took down the Walls he
undid all Harden Titans including her
shell so for almost the whole series
she's been sitting there in the basement
but now Annie is back and so all our
main characters are on the same side
it's been complicated as everyone's had
different motivations to fight at
different times but now they all agree
killing everyone in the world is not the
right move they got to stop Aaron but
Aaron has a head start the rumbling
Titans have made it to Marley but our
crew has a plan to cat up to him with
the uo's flying boat which is a plane so
it's a big fight at the Port against the
jurists which is tragic because many of
them were our former friends the jager's
leader flock is ready to stop him but oh
he shot he was the hero in his own story
but not in this one as they Ed the boat
to tow the plane Annie and armman start
talking turns out he visited her all the
time she was frozen yes Armen has a
crush on Annie and she thinks that's
sweet so we have a last minute romance
blooming what about a romance between
Mikasa and Aaron it's always been are
they just friends we'll see now on
Marley they get the plane ready to fly
but flock survived and stowed away oh
take some last shots now it's going to
take some more time to repair but
they're out of time the rumbling is here
and so it's hanji who's going to buy him
time and she flies off for an epic Last
Stand the Colossal Titans remember are
really hot so she goes out in a literal
blaze of glory the plane took off just
in time and now it's time to strategize
how do we stop Aaron Arwin and Mika hope
they can talk some sense into Aaron and
in fact Aaron brings him in for a
psychic combo and we finally get some
insight into what Aaron's Thinking turns
out he feels real bad about killing the
whole world but he still believes it's
the right thing to do and so he's going
through with this the only way to stop
me you'll have to kill me and so at an
Airbase Marans and eldians are united in
purpose as they send out their blimps to
make a Last Stand but Aaron's new Titan
body is a gigantic skeletal creepy thing
and Zeke's Beast Titan is under his
control and so real quick the blimps are
destroyed and so our crew is Humanity's
last hope they fly in on the plane jump
out of there all our main characters
here for one last ride Rina goes
straight for the Beast Titan there's the
hope that without Zeke's Royal Blood
Aaron won't be able to control the
founding Titan as the rest of them
prepare to fight their friend Aaron
joerger how will this epic Saga come to
an end find out in Attack on Titan the
final final
part if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and
movies